[Music]
and extremely expensive new how many
money submitted by Bart ejidos Filipino
baby hi we are making Filipino a wealthy
businessman spend 10 million on his
daughters very lavish wedding that's a
grip how long that's more money than I
will make a lie first of all [ __ ] your
daughter right literally might yeah how
much money does the dad have to drop 10
million like it's nothing he at 11
because 1 million times up
yep I want to know I wanna know I want
to know how much you may and does it
have an object so I contain all that and
more I want to know I want to know how
much you make so I could be the only one
to take your money
perfect I love that song it's better
than the original talk to Terry's just
kidding man oh it was a tie really shows
Joe Dawsey I'll kick you about was the
cause other side any fear no the fire is
big oh yeah I like that one
alright so this couple is named Lolita
of manova or Russian Russian who is
believed to be 24 years old she is the
daughter of an energy tycoon named Eldar
Osman ohm which is less I'm sorry did I
find it so interesting
he wasn't just think so the bad they
report him on the nose yes the daughter
is but it females have the afn spoon
oh all the females they have the same
last name but in the other you know
what's also interesting actually don't
even know how this show works I'm
probably [ __ ] it ups don't kill me
but like the Icelandic people's you know
how like if your dad is last or then
you're it your storage daughter so let's
do tto are and then if there are son
then it's like Thor's men or something
like that and it's it kind of changes
too so you know exactly through your
name like Magnussen do you eat if you're
mr. Magnussen then that means you're the
son of Magnus Magnusson right then does
that mean you're Magnus ensign Magnussen
saying the third grandchild is Magnussen
Stinson ya know is that Russian but then
what happens if you identify as a female
then you're Magnus then daughter
Magnus Anderson Magnussen endures Magnus
II and I don't know the pop honest the
Viking can really think of all that [ __ ]
did they you got lots of big fancies
they don't exist anymore
they still Vikings they still have to
have that Viking tradition Thorisdottir
Magnussen's and sentence and they oh you
were gonna sit on those myths yeah so I
don't know
Eldar on manag not worth betting but a
lot that 10 million is basically nothing
it's like the [ __ ] he's a Russian
oligarch of the billions yeah so the
groom his name is Gaspar avid Olli and
my center on and he is 29 years old his
father
oh my god he is so [ __ ] poor they're
both [ __ ] ball and why is the girl
dead pink like working yeah I don't
understand where they're reporting it
that way either but when like you're
only reading article I just talked about
both wealthy families coming together
what additionally I'd be a daughter the
dowry got it
the daughters family's supposed to pay
for the wedding what tradition normal
[ __ ] what does that mean like the
American everybody all over the world I
believe so yeah [ __ ] I've been
traditionally I think tradition is what
is supposed to be though no joke
the daughters family supposed to pay for
the wedding we're taking the burden of
taking a Joshua's a pretty big burden
I thought Southeast Asians pay for the
dollar with daughter with gold bricks
and goats the dowry that is the same
thing do you think about it but then the
bear family throws the wedding yeah but
some cultures they kidnap the wife and
then the groom's family just have a
party do it that's still happening till
this day it's so [ __ ] sad where
people were guys kidnapped brides heard
that's in the Hmong culture they go to
the window and then they say guess what
your daughter's out our house come to
our [ __ ] house for a wedding and then
the whole family comes and then there's
food and celebration and everyone's
having a great time except for the bride
because she's just like [ __ ] out
right last night oh yeah it is
[ __ ] [ __ ] was a documentary in one
of those like not Kazakhstan but like
those that area take a little Vicks time
I do one of those I know it is I saw the
video it's [ __ ] up like they're just
it's a girl like we're girlfriends just
walk down the street I caught our car
full of guys just run out take the girl
put a thing over her head like a veil
and that's it she's someone's bride she
likes lying usually though it's the it's
a boyfriend/girlfriend but he doesn't
ask her she just assumes it's time and
she doesn't even know and sometimes her
own female friends set her up to do that
too and everyone's having a blast but
the girl is like I wanted to go to
college [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah
man I wasn't ready for that [ __ ] I don't
be a tennis champ [ __ ] yeah I
know but then he just don't even care
just [ __ ] take her and you know
what's crazy is every time they're doing
these abduct Asians
adoptions are determined action of
abductions I got too excited they have
some [ __ ] Kazakhstan techno playing
in the background in the bath the
kidnapped bad is like to teach teach
teach teach gonna teach math girls that
or whatever they can't even deny it they
can't be like I don't want to do it all
stare look there frowned upon the whole
community this is a documentary real
night I saw this a live taping of a
kidnapping
it was also probably a Mongolian
tradition I got passed down back to this
couple oh yeah a $10,000,000 yeah they
went all out for the wing so this is the
couple Oh she'll get aful so great look
good-looking couple
he's a good-looking guy to agree on it
but he's he's like she's way out of his
League he doesn't know about that before
they Baltimore same leg oh and that fish
hook up Reba she's beautiful yeah yeah
but you've got 750 million that must
make all his head all her sad he also
saw a dozen telecommunications and he
also owned businesses and I'm sure
anybody named Zangief I don't know I'm
going to show you guys a clip of the
wedding anything borscht I like that
character is Bob all these names are
dope big star orbital demetri demetri
George oh brother
so this wedding what this wedding was
held in Hollywood's Dolby theatre oh
here here oh and seeing the home of the
Oscars where the [ __ ] is the Dolby
Theatre in Hollywood
yes she's not but like what's Crete is
it on if you want the [ __ ] address I
don't even remember a Holly theater
mirror isn't it any home like where you
guys used to live
can we hear the [ __ ] 10 million
dollar wedding please I don't want to
know the [ __ ] geographical location
of this [ __ ] another something new my
backyard I don't know they just [ __ ]
make them and you know they helping
officers
you interview yep I don't know which
place now you know but you clever after
shrine and see and I know what that is
he still beat up on me a little [ __ ]
old-fashioned - it looks like the thing
on a wedding cake wet [ __ ] which one the
actual figurines all the carbon either
the dead the figurine a they do look
like the figurine - wait this whole time
I was thinking it was a 10 million
dollar birthday party huh why are you so
here we go
oh and already get another this video
broke Wow why are they showing you the
other lengths to people party people
party people there we go that's it dad
I was suing the bill he looks hella yeah
[Music]
Wow their flowers expensive kooky
combust anyone
you guys got Davis so at your wedding
though they don't have that it's already
better your wedding was featuring David
so that's what I'm saying
Lady Gaga they'll give anything to sing
at my wedding I want to want that nah
[ __ ] that she's gonna take all the
attention from me that's my day [ __ ] oh
yes I photos of yeah I can layer cake
with that edible dog god I wish your
marriage fails Lady gaga
I remember to stick me that's what they
say what people that have crazy lavish
weddings they don't do I knew it because
they're trying to overcompensate for
their love for the lack of love because
for me if I want to marry the woman
that's gonna write or die by my side I
do in the dumpster
I'll go book or just [ __ ] Airbnb a
house cute cute hey guys when it was
pretty cool yeah so there's more or she
was on get on yeah I thought fun get up
yup yeah we [ __ ] pp put this [ __ ] we
gotta have like the whole red carpet up
beautiful though it looks like there's
more performers big guests do this Wow
yeah you know what I want to know what
that place smell like not like which
people this interview is [ __ ] huge
that's a beautiful place
I want to see the food though absolutely
[ __ ] borscht and [ __ ] beat today
yeah centerpieces
[ __ ] huge all upset and they're still
going to be that [ __ ] on to you
that's got a tank [ __ ] centerpiece
home is always a [ __ ] on see that
[ __ ] has to take variance in our
culture drug know that Asian culture
truly every culture every [ __ ]
culture you can't put it aside but it
seemed like this I knew the truth
that was Chinese and he was dating a
Filipino girl these [ __ ] went
to the wedding that we went to together
we do some zip locks they [ __ ] took
the food in the peanut oh yo that's like
there were some ghetto [ __ ] I
friend she went with her family to her
[ __ ] all-you-can-eat like buffet type
of thing why did they [ __ ] bring
ziploc bag and Tupperware and like she
was like shameless but she recorded like
what her mom was doing like [ __ ]
putting [ __ ] in Tupperware I'm like it's
so crazy dude yeah Jason Derulo is also
in this whoa no one cares about Jason
different [ __ ] gotta make sure
we know his name in every song is [ __ ] I
know it's been five hundred thousand
dollars on just lower can I have their
money but like not their problems yeah I
don't want their drama
I don't want fake family I don't want
fake friends I don't want none of that
[ __ ] I want to be rich but I don't want
to spend money like a rich person though
I do alright hey what's up guys thanks
for watching we are going to regularly
start posting content on the JK films
Instagram so make sure you follow us
there a lot videos click over here
[Music]